A is for AI B is for BT C is for chat
Bots D is for Deep Mind e is for
explainable AI F is for facial
recognition G is for Glam H is for human
in the loop I is for image recognition J
is for Jupiter notebooks K is for K
means Plus+ L is for llms M is for
machine learning n is for natural
language processing O is for optical
character recognition P is for promp
engineering Q is for Quantum error
correction R is for reinforcement
learning s is for security T is for
Transformers U is for unsupervised
learning V is for vertex AI W is for
water marking X is for XG boost Y is for
y I know I know it doesn't technically
start with Y but he me Z is for zero
knowledge proof q r s t u v